[موسيقى]
كان هذا أول مؤتمر صحفي كبير لبوتين
منذ غزوه لأوكرانيا
منذ ما يقرب من عامين.
أجاب زعيم الكرملين لساعات على أسئلة منتقاة بعناية
تعيد صياغة الأهداف الروسية فيما
يسميه عمليته العسكرية الخاصة،
سيكون هناك سلام عندما
نحقق أهدافنا التي يحلمون بها.  لم يتغير
هذا هو نزع السلاح
وتكثيف أوكرانيا
ووضعها المحايد. فللمرة الأولى كشف بوتين عن وجود
أكثر من 600 ألف جندي حاليا
في منطقة الصراع، لكنه لم يعط أي
إشارة إلى الخسائر التي تشير
تقديرات المخابرات الأمريكية إلى أنها
مرتفعة للغاية، لكن الزعيم الروسي فعل ذلك.
تشير إلى أنه يعتقد أن التصميم الغربي بشأن
أوكرانيا قد ينهار بشكل كبير حيث أن
المساعدات الأمريكية لأوكرانيا متوقفة في
الكونجرس الأمريكي
اليوم.
قد تنتهي الهدية الترويجية يومًا ما
ويبدو أنها
ستنتهي. سأل أحد المراسلين الروس بوتين
عن المكاسب الأوكرانية الأخيرة عبر
نهر دينو، إنها مجرد مناطق صغيرة
قال بوتين إن القوات الأوكرانية فيها
الآن معرضة بشكل كبير
ولا أعرف لماذا يفعلون
ذلك.  دفع شعبهم
للقتل، إنها رحلة ذهاب فقط للقوات الأوكرانية
والسبب في ذلك سياسي
لأن القادة الأوكرانيين يتوسلون
الدول الأجنبية للحصول على المساعدة، لقد كان هذا
حدثًا منظمًا للغاية مع
أسئلة تم فحصها بعناية ولكن البث المباشر
للنصوص العامة أثار ضجة  بعض
التحديات المفاجئة، كم عدد اليخوت التي
طلبها بوتين، سأل إحدى الرسائل المجهولة لماذا
يختلف واقعك عن واقعنا،
سأل آخر لمحة خلف
الستار ربما لمشاهدة يفكر بعض الروس
حقًا
في لحظة غريبة
ظهر طفل روسي في رسالة فيديو يسأل
إذا تم استبدال عائلتها
بمشرف آلي، فقد قامت بتشغيل مقطع
فيديو غير عادي لما قالت إنه
صورة مزيفة عميقة
لبوتين وهو يسأل الزعيم الروسي الحقيقي
عما إذا كان لديه العديد من الأزواج المزدوجة، فأنت أول من
أجاب بوتين بالطبع هناك
شائعات عن ذلك  أرى أن
الكثير منكم يمكن أن يشبهوني
ويتحدثوا بصوتي لكنني فكرت في الأمر
وقررت أن شخصًا واحدًا فقط
يجب أن يشبهني ويتحدث
بصوتي وهذا الشخص سيكون أنا في
هذه الأثناء بينما كان بوتين يحاكم
الصحفي الأمريكي إيفان غيرشكوفيتش في الواقع
ظهر في استئناف آخر ضد
احتجازه بتهمة التجسس المزعوم،
على الرغم من أن بوتين أشار إلى أن المحادثات
لإعادة الأمريكيين المحتجزين
مستمرة. ليس الأمر أننا نرفض
عودتهم، لا نرفض، نريد
التفاوض، ويجب أن تكون الاتفاقات
مقبولة ومرضية للجانبين.
وتريد روسيا رغم ذلك أن
فرصة ماثيو لقناة سي إن إن موسكو لا تزال غير واضحة